today we're gonna take you back back
before studio sets before franchise
leaves before dr. pepper sponsorships to
a time when games weren't solved when
there was no such thing as the LCS and
probe League of Legends was just a bunch
of tournaments when one Russian team had
smarted the world in the biggest
competition was musta five and the thing
everyone in the world would agree that
toughest opponent would always really be
Moscow but when Moscow 5 changed
everything
[Music]
it all started with Kim Empire oh no
Ken's gonna get caught out here by also
it will be gossip actually their turn to
get your does use IOT gosu actually
popping his own otiwu oh my god
count the salty backed it with it Wow
they would not expect see that s Kate
just got it destroyed when they started
playing together in 2011 team Empire
quickly made a name for themselves with
their unusual champion picks and their
hyper aggressive strategy Empire will
forever be known for the Empire a play
that saw a series of layered ultimate
abilities centered around Ganges nunu
alt it was unlike anything League fans
had ever seen before
and people remembered it for years five
give me a triple ko dude that's not a
[ __ ] Empire no we don't like fake
Empire dude we're not where she cut
ourselves on fire after the 2011 season
team empires League of Legends roster
was bought by the Russian eSports our
Moscow 5 they were young they were wild
and they were just getting started
Moscow 5 thought through the group stage
at the IEM season 6 World Championship
in Hannover without dropping a single
match they will pick up that Nexus at
Moscow 5 for no other group I think
they're guaranteed to be T seconds to my
finalists there will be playing on
Friday they continued their rampage into
the bracket with a swept theology and
then took it to Dignitas in the finals
they played fast they hunted kills early
and they hunted kills off goosey pepper
look looked he's ready to flash engage
here he has head puts career away
Manchester gets caught out with a poor
price scars gonna go down here that
quick quick gal must verify keeping it
real the same way they have to
throughout the tournament some crazy
crazy engages already
this was league of legends like the
world had never seen before like a pro
scene didn't even know was possible the
world champions must go
[Music]
in season two League of Legends was a
whole different ball game
straight up it was just the Wild West
we're gonna see with it wow I just a hit
with an orange that's pretty impressive
nice shot there was little scouting or
even a real decided upon meta game
players were famous for signature
champions or play styles and certain
picks were considered good just cuz
everybody said they were in a lot of
ways Pro play was just a slightly more
organized version of solo queue and by
modern standards the game was slow teams
like CLG EU team solomid and SK gaming
all decided that they wanted to play for
a late game especially CLG EU who always
tried to out firm their opponents and
Team fight late I wasn't impressed
bitter like play style was more annoyed
by the by that because their whole team
was trying to pick some scaling 5v5 calm
like froggen was playing always and um
this champion was really broken back
then it worked
but moscowfive had something to say
about the tension between these two
teams play styles fostered an incredible
rivalry CLG EU was a slow plodding team
that load their opponents into
submission
Moscow 5 went for the throat and that
rivalry came to a head at Dreamhack
summer 2012 where the two teams played
one of the most famous series in
competitive league of legends history
and CLG you may know his most famous
comebacks the game has ever seen the
kick comes out on towards get your head
foot sorry bull price alex is now the
target fighting Ricky picking up another
kill I cut off for me this is that's CLG
pull off the big E's come back that
we've ever seen in League of Legends at
this level in a world where competitive
league of Legends was mostly just a
series of tournaments
moscowfive picked up a lot of
first-place trophies that year
ultimately their 2012 run was one of the
most dominant streaks in the game's
history the team itself was like very
serious and they just into towards
people and they just like yes when
placing games not
a must to to entertain people that's
like have fun but what might be more
interesting than the fact that this
little Russian team blew everyone's
minds was how they did it these days
we've got the numbers there are
formalized link structures and scrim
blocks and hundreds of games played and
analyzed every single year teams have
coaches and analysts and resources
dedicated to getting to the bottom of
each new meta and innovating it and so
with each new patch the game is solved
anew
which makes what moscowfive did even
more special they went against the grain
in every way I remember after the game
when we went around and we went around
to shake hands and say good game well
you didn't want to shake my hand because
I was playing easy champions but it was
the thing was it up no it wasn't after
that game it was group stage she was
like I feel fairly a player so I didn't
want to shake his hand well the rest of
the world decided to play late-game
champions like anivia and Karthus
moscowfive picked ELISA and Shyvana and
went for early game skirmishes they
forced you to play the game their way
TSM I can't really pinpoint a single
mistake that they made
it's just m5 rookies so strong playing
their own game they're forcing everybody
else to play their game
as season 2 worlds was getting underway
the only word you could use to describe
the meadow was like it was so slow in
fact that fans would cheer whenever a
player killed a ward wicked on traffic
they do get it people cheering what
kills now it's time to stretch it
happens because this cave has been so
much smoking but those fans had one hope
to break the mold moscowfive
debate entered the tournament as
favourites and it seemed like destiny
that they'd cap off an incredible year
with a world championship title and they
were in a good position to do so with a
bye through the group stage they met
Invictus gaming in their quarterfinals
match and quickly shows them how
moscowfive
play league of legends the fights of
episodic addition to come safe
experience good job kid almost all he
does get taken down visiting and a
chance to attack the die falling to
Moscow fight that cue Alexei's
very big but it's diamondprox with a
double kill they're chased undefeated is
just too strong in this completely
spells barren of 29 minutes for Moscow
5mq so you guys made some interesting
choices in champion pigs with what was
the strategy behind that was that
tailored specifically to Invictus game
here is that just something you've been
working on we just speak broken heroes
they looked fast focused and ready to
dominate but that momentum faded all too
quickly going into worlds most analysts
thought that the only team that could
challenge Moscow 5 was CLG you or maybe
the up-and-coming Korean powerhouse
azubu frost no one saw the real threat
company resolute Bennett there's a
crescendo I'm gonna be big damage Darien
will go down to alternate was you three
via sleep no actually he has it a cup in
time so they will have some time to
grieve the disruption here they just
split up and five completely barren is
there's 53 to 41,000 gold this is
looking so good for the Taipei assassins
right now a three on floor but they're
getting pushed out oh my gosh the
counter-attack golden pepper goes down
we've now got a foreign team on the map
and barons gotta be students in ten
seconds diamondprox goes down the
inhibitor is open the double kill comes
out fast on five looking very grim right
now taipei assassins look to take down
the last nexus 10 and they will try
moscow 5 for the league of legends
championship playoffs in what was a
heart-wrenching upset for moscow 5 fans
they were bested by the upstart eventual
champions taipei assassins and just like
that as quickly as they slaughter their
opponents all year long Moscow 5 season
2 run was
bittersweet looking back there is no
better word to describe Moscow fives
2012 they shone so bright and dominated
it like we'd never seen before but that
spark they did all too quickly after
that world's things got a little weird
mr. CEO Demetrius million s was arrested
after what was allegedly a two year
investigation by the FBI cybercrime
division and the team was disbanded
gambit gaming another Russian org picked
up the roster heading at the season 3
but that's around the time that League
of Legends got a lot more formal Joe
we've been building up to this moment
for what feels like a year or plus I
don't know but it is gonna be season 3
getting in the way here in Europe last
plenty of the biggest names from season
2 we're competing in the NA and the EU
LCS gone were the days of esoteric
tournament structures and unknown
masters rising to the top of the gaming
world and though gambit were a strong
team they never really found that same
success they have in 2012 again now is
it going big they're going for all the
kills they've gotten all the turrets
they've gotten everything they wanted in
this game including the win they lost
the first one but were able to hit up
warm after that first match and find the
win over camp it here in the
quarterfinals you may not have heard
about Moscow 5 before today and will
probably never see another League of
Legends team quite like them for that
one year those five guys did everything
different they did everything in their
way and we worked and they'll be
remembered forever
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages